so with Regulators hanging over crypto
like a thousand pound piano on a rope
can the industry actually recover for
reactions bringing crypto Guru Tech
investor podcast host Anthony pompliano
founder of Pop Investments the home of
the pump podcast and I'm just going to
call you like everybody else Anthony
pump I hope you don't mind uh what's
your take on on coinbase's scrap with
the SEC I mean at some point this fight
has got to end
yeah first of all thank you for having
me um I don't know if this is
necessarily one single company right I
think that there's important to find
common ground in these conversations to
start I think that both companies and
Regulators they want to to push out bad
behavior uh of Industry there's fraud
they want to get rid of that if there's
people doing the ferris things they want
to get rid of that not only do they want
to get rid of the bad behavior but they
want to encourage good behavior they
want free and fair markets they want to
have Innovations built we want to create
jobs want to create all sorts of
financial Innovation Etc here in the
United States what I think with the
disagreement is how do we do that so we
have agreement it's just the
disagreement on how we get there is
really important and one of the pieces
that is always missing in these
conversations is that ultimately I think
that we want competition in the United
States the United States was built on
competition and in order to keep that
competition we have to remember that we
want the competitors in the arena to
actually be deciding who is the winners
and who are losers we don't want
Regulators we don't want courts we don't
want lawyers we want people who are
building products to go out into the
free market and compete and let the
market decide who the winners are and I
think that's where you're getting
frustrations correctly on both sides of
this debate is they feel like there is
not that free market competition going
on so we can get back to that I think
that a lot of people be happy well we're
showing our viewers I don't know if you
can see the the show Anthony I know
you're like on the show so it's hard to
see the show when you're actually doing
the show we're 74 on bitcoin this year
you talked about Winners we also have a
chart of Bitcoin versus the dollar the
US dollar has been weakening bitcoin's
been strengthening how much of this do
you think is related to our top story
which is of course the banking crisis is
Bitcoin a beneficiary of you know the
Silicon Valley and First Republic woes
there's a phrase in the Bitcoin
community that says Bitcoin solves this
and I think that there's a number of
different reasons why people are
attracted to bitcoin if you look at the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
in the United States Bitcoin fixes that
it's a programmatic monetary policy if
you look at the concerns around the debt
limit the potential deep part of the
United States investors are seeking an
alternative Bitcoin fixes that being in
a separate alternative Financial system
if you even look at the banking crisis
Bitcoin fixes that because it gives you
the ability to be your own bank hold
your private keys not your keys not your
coins and so I don't think that Bitcoin
necessarily solves every problem in the
world I frankly think that there's Fair
critiques of the Bitcoin world where
people get ahead of themselves a lot but
I do think that there's a number of
concerns in the Legacy Financial world
right now that Bitcoin specifically was
built to solve and so when you see an
asset up 74 the best performing asset in
q1 and you could look over the
three-year performance we're not talking
about an asset that is flat or down
where many assets are Bitcoin is up over
350 since the start of this pandemic era
and so just as people in 2020 we're
saying printing trillions of dollars
emergency cuts to zero and interest
rates was going to lead to inflation and
Bitcoin would be the fastest horse in
that inflation race that turned out to
be true and so I think that at some
point we're 15 years into this at some
point investors have to say regardless
of whether you are a bull or a bear the
market is the referee and the market has
determined that Bitcoin is highly
valuable and I don't think that's going
to change anytime soon it's like the
other the other saying should be Anthony
what if FTX failed and the Bitcoin
Community didn't seem to care because it
certainly does not uh Anthony pompliano
appreciate your views thank you
absolutely thanks so much